the first weeks on my very first project
in Consulting I felt like I should not
be here I felt like I was working
together on a team with other associates
other consultants and these people
seemed so above and beyond so much
smarter so much more capable of me but
the truth is the learning curve is quite
Steep and what you would only see is
that where these people are maybe one
year ten year two years tenure this is
such a development step from a UR or
someone who just started out compared to
someone who's already doing all of this
after one or two years because what you
don't realize in the beginning is that
there are lots of little tips and tricks
that might make you to be perceived as
very confident very knowledgeable